hello everyone and welcome to another
very exciting game from the prestigious
mr dodgy invitational 2.0 uh it's nils
grindelius versus anish geary
and it uh well the game just features a
very nice attack so i thought you guys
might enjoy it and like i said there are
so many blitz games being played every
day in this
wonderful tournament so do use hashtag
suggestion that
suggests a game that you you enjoy and
also i would just like to mention there
is a very strong tournament today being
played on leeches
uh i will put a link to it in the
description below i might even
stream it if i manage the time uh it
starts in two hours uh from the time
that i'm making this video
uh it will uh feature uh some very
strong players including uh even
character
he was the 2019 european champion he was
the world youth chat youth
champion he was the world junior
champion he's the uh two times croatian
champion so
now you might get a chance to play
against him if uh if if you guys have
time to join us
uh so uh first link in the description
below now getting back to the game
uh uh niels grandilius versus anishigiri
let's check it out and also uh the
second link uh
if you haven't seen it i will put uh
shotish's game against magnus carlsen
that he played i think it was in the
2014 olympiad
uh so do check that out as well it's the
one where i completely messed up uh
my uh well i i thought that croatia
would win the
the football championship and then we
didn't but i made the video up front so
that's a bit weird but if you completely
ignore that you know the game is
actually quite nice so do check that out
as well
uh will be the second link in the
description below now getting back to
the game
uh grand deluxe with the white pieces
opens with e4
we have c5 by anish of course he goes
for his chestable opening
knight to f3 we have d6 and d4 striking
in the center
captures captures and of course knight
to f6 we have knight to c3
and a6 now going for the night of
sicilian we have bishop
to c4 uh nicely developing the bishop
uh we have e6 and now comes bishop back
to b3
always a useful move as the queen might
come to c7 then you're going to have
problems also you don't want that bishop
to be in reach of the b5 or d5 pawn so
it's better to just put it on b3 right
away so
b5 and now we have castles here we have
bishop to e7
uh you might think but why not uh kick
away this knight and then grab the e4
pawn
you could do this but many a player has
lost the game this way for example if
you do something like this and grab the
pawn
then you're gonna run into problems for
example rookie one attacks the knight
and now while you can play d5 and it
seems like you've
just grabbed the pawn and now you're
completely winning uh the problem is uh
let's say black goes white goes bishop
to f4 how do you continue the game for
example
bishop to d6 uh bla white can just
easily play
rook captures on e4 and now you're in a
big trouble because if bishop captures
bishop then you
grab the bishop with the rook and of
course if you capture here
then you might run into knight captures
on e6 and that's just terrible bishop
captures you're going to play bishop
captures on d6
and now the king is still in the center
of the board uh the queen nicely defends
the bishop the bishop prevents the king
from castling and this is a
pretty bad position for black so one of
the reasons why
not uh why maybe playing b4 in this
position isn't so great
there are positions where playing b4 is
great this is not one of them
so here bishop to e7 and now comes queen
to f3
again a very nice developing move with
the queen
in some lines there there are
possibilities of a double attack here
uh but this again is not one of them so
queen to b6 this has all been played
before nothing new here
uh if you if you try this with e5 going
after the knight and the rook just
bishop to b7 the queen now nicely guards
the b7 square so this is possible
so bishop to e3 now you're threatening
some very nasty discoveries as the queen
is on b6 and
geary moves it back to b7 uh we have
queen to g3
and here uh anish just castle's king
side you don't really have to worry
about the g7 pawn this is not really a
target
you could if you play something like b4
uh white can never grab the g7 pawn
because rook g8 now both the queen and
the
knight are under attack so instead after
this queen to g3 we have castles by
anish
uh and uh grendelius immediately jumps
into the attack so here
bishop to h6 now threatening to
checkmate anish with queen captures and
g7
but anish just defends it knights the e8
we have rook after e1 now adding a
defender here preparing to bring the
other rook to d1
that will complete your development uh
and then you can
decide what to do from then uh then on
and then
now comes b4 so attacking the knight
here
uh and here uh interesting uh fact is
that this position has been reached
before
and in both of those games knight to d5
was played the knight to d5
is the absolute strongest move here for
white and this is probably
what gary was prepared for even though
it's uh
it's very hard to play this with black
when white plays
knight to d5 for example if white goes
knight to d5 you can't really
accept the knight because after let's
say captures and captures uh the queen
is under attack once the queen moves
you're gonna lose the rook
and if you try defending the rook then
just bring the bishop back to e3
now a lot of very nasty discoveries are
coming the knight can move uh the threat
and checkmate
so anything is possible here uh but the
white would be winning so what you would
have to do after knight to d5
is just uh something like king to h8 and
make room for the for the rook and g8
but now let's say
captures with ch captures without check
but you have to recapture back
and the bishop to g5 and now again it's
a very uh difficult position for black
you could play some like f6 but the
dangerous bishop goes back
and it's uh well you've ruined your
position
and it's going to be a better game for
white so
in any case if you were wondering why
what happens here
uh but grendels did not play knights to
d5 here instead he played knights the a4
this is not as potent as knights to d5
but
it is a new move in the position so
already as a move 14 we have a
completely new game
uh let's see how anish responds to this
he starts by playing
not that he starts by playing a5 okay
you uh defend your your b from b4 pawn
once again
and you can now use the a6 square for
your pieces if needed we have rook
8 to d1 uh grenades now has developed
all of his pieces uh
and king the h8 now you will be able to
bring the rook to g8 to help out
with the defense of your king side
bishop to
g5 now also uh after this
just capturing the bishop is also
possible because the g pawn is no longer
pinned
so bishop g5 and now knight to f6 and
black
really has a nice position here it's
very hard for white to
continue attacking here but niels always
finds a way and there's a saying
interest it's always easier to attack
than to defend
uh here niels starts with queen to h4
this frees up the third rank and now you
can start
bringing those rooks to help out with
the attack uh we have knight to c6 and
he's just continuous development
and now knight captures on c6 we have
queen captures
and of course rook to d3 now preparing
to bring this rook into the attack
uh and now uh what do you play here well
uh rook the h3 kinda
is coming so uh giri just uh played e5
and he stopped this because the bishop
now covers the h3 square
but it is not enough so uh feel free to
pause the video here and try to find
the winning idea for niels while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
incredible idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's
rook captures on d6 i'm i'm only kidding
no it's not
that would be crazy the the correct is
rook to f3
and it's uh wow i know you're thinking
but what does this move even do
well it adds a third attacker here to
the f6 knight and there's not
all that much you can do here uh problem
is if you try something like bishop to
e6 then maybe
uh maybe counter this light square
bishop here
uh the the real threat is just rook
captures and f6 that's the problem and
after everything is traded here captures
captures and captures
you will not be able to capture back
because if you do then
queen captures with check and now a
second rook lift wins the game
uh rook the g3 is coming there's no
defense against that
uh you might try to prolong it a little
bit with some like bishop to g4 we're
just gonna attack it let's say queen
captures defends it
but now h3 again just wins the game
there there's no way for black to hold
this
if you play h5 we're just gonna play h
captures and now after captures
well uh just queen g5 check for example
king moves and now
rook captures attacks the queen also
threatens checkmate with rook to h4
so they are completely winning for white
so it's a really difficult position to
defend for black
anish finds the uh the most resilient
idea and that is a rook to g8
so now what do you play here problem is
if you continue with the same idea
uh that we've uh discussed for example
rook captures bishop captures and bishop
captures
now black will be able to capture it
because after queen captures
rook can block with rook to g7 that's
the idea of rook to g8
and if you try a second rook lift with
the idea of doubling up here it's not a
problem just bishop moves and then the
other rook will also help out with the
defense so just rook g3
black goes to rook to g8 and anish can
uh defend this
uh however after this rook the g8 move
uh of course grand daley's played the
strongest move possible he played bishop
captures on f7 now attacks the rook here
and now uh anish uh well there are some
moves that prolong the game like rook to
f8 but anish grabbed the knight hoping
for the best
but now once again uh for the second
time and last time
in this video feel free to pause the
video and win this game for nils
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations again on not
doing anything weird like rook captures
on f6 that was then
it's okay here now it's just not as
potent uh but for those of you who found
the exact move really congratulations
that move is bishop to g6
and it was in this position on move 22
that anishi resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh mate is being threatened we're just
gonna eliminate the knight and deliver
checkmate here
and there's really not all that much you
can do if you try h6
we're just gonna grab here on h6 and
that's it captures captures
the knight blocks and queen captures on
h7 or any any of the
other lines but after bishop to g6
there's just nothing for anish to play
here
so while niels won this brilliant
attacking game
uh it was actually anish who won the who
won the match i think six and a half to
four and a half so
congratulations to anish as well yeah
and this achievement achievement i
i went through all of the games not all
of them were finished while i chose this
one
but i thought this one was nicest and
that you guys would enjoy this one the
most so
yeah i decided to show that one uh so uh
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
uh do
uh suggest games using hashtag
suggestions so i uh i can
spot them as it's very hard to go
through all of them i do go through most
of them but it's easier when you guys
you should
use hashtag suggestion uh do join uh the
leaches tournament the first link in the
description below and if you
i haven't seen the game shotish versus
magnus at the second link in the
description below
it's an older video for when my videos
were still it at only 30 frames per
second
but you know what what can we do uh we
will remake
it at some point uh but do check it out
as well uh so yeah
uh once again uh thank you all uh i
would like to thank uh david
tony mo at guitar jeffrey waldron rocket
vishnu and richard black for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this prestigious
tournament that is the mr dodgy
invitational 2.0 checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day